professor your cups else on your the
number of the Economic Sciences prize
committee please tell us it bit more
about this year spice what kind of
research shall be awarded so generally
the research is a common denominator is
research on consumption and more
specifically details contributions or
divided up to three core components one
has to deal with deals with so-called
demand system trying to understand what
consumption people consumption choices
people make such function of prices of
these goods and their income and various
other potential important factors the
other important contribution deals with
more thinking about aggregate
relationship between a grid consumption
and a great the income and where he has
shown that in order to understand these
patterns in the data in a better way we
need to start from the individual and
start to understand individual behavior
to then a great up to the to the
National Lab and finally has done a very
important work on measuring and
understanding living standards and
poverty in developing countries and
among his many contributions or
developing tools to measure poverty in
cases where we don't have very good
price and quality data on the goods that
people are consumer when did you do is
most important research focus yeah I had
the research on demand system was done
in the late 1970s and much of his work
in
on the a great relationship between
income and consumption was done in the
latter part of the 1980s and from 90s
forward he has done a lot of work on on
developing economics it is still active
research is still a very active
researcher very much so more findings to
look forward to I probably thinks it
okay as the politics just anything to
learn from this kind of research yeah I
think us as policymakers you have a lot
to learn from this research I think all
three of his core contributions have a
direct link to policies or demand system
is a tool you can do to evaluate
different types of economic policy
proposals like changes in taxes there's
work on an aggregate income and
consumption you know it's an important
issue when it comes to stabilization
policy to understand the correct type of
access you take is inside of
understanding individual behavior is
virtually important find this work on
poverty had a large impact how you
actually go about you measure poverty in
many developing countries it's the press
about consumption as the ordinary
consumer and thing to learn about this
like you and me I think we do first of
all I think we do because we care about
the welfare of poor individuals of poor
households in developing countries and
in order to do anything about that we
need to measure see how many they are
and where they live and what you can do
about it but of course also when we
think about government's changing
various economic policies I think it's
important for us to know how it will
affect our welfare was it hard to make
the decision this year this is only my
second year in the committee so I don't
have so much to compare with but it's
it's a long process so but I think we're
in the end we were very much in
agreement that this was a very good
choice how do you know resurrect when he
heard the news yeah I know him a little
bit I thought he was in a bit of a state
of shock he is usually a very elegant
and speaker at the answers in long
sentences but the replies we got were
very short but I think he was very very
happy extreme poverty has decreased
never on today can Angus beats a little
research help us to have the decrease to
continue for long yeah i think the word
i think primarily a angers work on
unproven it is how you measure it in the
best possible way and I think measuring
poverty well is important to be order in
which you evaluate what policies works
and what do not and here he has made a
huge impact I think there's if you look
at the data there's nothing that tells
us that this reduction in absolute
poverty will not continue but of course
we we never know and finally has the
Lord written some kind of book for the
big audience that we can read if are
interesting in this topic yes just a
year or two ago he came out with a book
called The Great Escape which I remember
correctly which talks a little bit about
his own life but also more generally
about partners we observe in today
long long development in income and
poverty a welfare that I think is a very
good book to thank you very much thank
you very much